[Music]
happy holidays from Honest Trailers
we'll be back in one week with some of
this year's biggest hits but until then
here's a bunch of old trailers we found
next to Walt's head in the Disney Vault
[Music]
from the studio they brought you Snow
White Fantasia and the story of
menstruation comes the fairy tale that's
been adapted for film again and again
and again and again and again and again
and again and again and coming soon to a
theater near you again Cinderella
foreign
classic that will cancel out all the
empowering things your daughter learned
from Frozen
to the women where girls are taught to
be pushovers do all the housework and
that their problems will disappear if
they're hot enough to land a rich
husband
get Swept Away by the tale of Cinderella
an orphan girl enslaved to her step
family who is either a powerful Druid
that can talk to animals
or years of being locked away in a
castle knitting sweaters for mice have
slowly driven her mad yes I know it's a
lovely morning but
it was a lovely dream too yep definitely
crazy
but everything will change when she
meets her fairy godmother a guardian
angel who's waited years to improve
Cinderella's life in any way instead of
helping her out when her parents died or
when her step family forced her into
slavery thanks for the dress lady but it
would have been more helpful if you
bibbity bobbity called Child Protective
Services like eight years ago
even though Cinderella's name is the
title spend more than half the movie
watching a cat try to contain the army
of vermin who have infested every corner
of the house and for all his reasonable
efforts to contain the rodent horde gets
Bran Stark out the window
Savor the age-old Love Story between a
prince who couldn't be bothered to find
his own wife and a king so desperate for
heirs he doesn't care whose uterus his
son uses as a baby Factory whether it's
a Hermit maid who talks to mice or just
someone with the same shoe size this
slipper may fit any number of girls
that's his problem whatever
so travel back to a simpler time and
sing along to the classic songs you've
loved since childhood like the song that
inspires false hope this song is about
deception
most dreams just don't come true
but I am the rare except
ion and pretty and cute
the cute little mice song
and the oscar-nominated gibberish song
Blanc
anything Rhymes if you make up the words
slippity zappity flippity floppity these
Raiders clearly were drunk
story I ain't saying she a gold digger
Ron Stoker's Dracula the Kardashians
Wilford Brimley Prince foot fetish Rosie
O'Donnell Modest Mouse and unrealistic
expectations of relationships that girls
carry into adulthood
[Music]
I know the Stepmom was bad but good luck
with the father-in-law if anything goes
wrong
[Music]
you loved hook you think pan looks kinda
cool and you laughed your butt off at
NBC's live version Peter Pan has found a
mother
oh yeah
now revisit the animated classic that
will make you say this is way creepier
than I remembered Peter Pan prepare for
a film about an immortal trickster who
spies on you through your bedroom window
sprinkles you with dust that makes you
feel like you're flying then kidnaps you
to a war to an island where full-grown
adults Force orphans to join their ranks
or die it's like a magical sedan
leave your everyday worries behind as
you travel to Neverland and trade them
in for more serious worries like being
burned alive
[Music]
drowned by mermaids only trying to drown
her or having your throat slit by
Pirates and join The Lost Boys an
all-male group of motherless furries who
live underneath a tree that is clearly
still used for hanging people
Hangman's tree this is a kids story
right want to hear about the time I cut
off Hook's hand and threw it to the
crocodile see this magical realm Through
The Eyes of the darling children three
darling children who turned out okay
even though they were raised by a dog
kid left home alone and live with his
rageaholic who looks nothing like them
but they sure look a lot like Peter Pan
and their mom definitely believes in Him
Mrs darling believed that Peter Pan was
the spirit of you just saying opposing
Peter Pan's fairy dictatorship is
Captain James Hook a man who's given up
pirating to focus all his energy on
murdering a twee and when he fails takes
out his impotent rage on his life
partner's me or really just anyone
whoa did he just kill that guy
but it's not all Darkness violence and
Oedipus complexes you can be our mother
if you were a kiss there's plenty of
sexism to go around too get on with it
girl a jealous female can be tricked
into anything girls talk too much yes
but who cares about sexism because
Disney makes up for it by including lots
of roles for Native Americans oh well I
don't even remember that part
wow that is really bad
[Music]
okay enough
[Music]
stop those Red Skins know this island
just switch to another Disney movie well
well not that one
[Music]
please no don't show that one show a
different one see I've seen all that too
oh that one's so much worse
these are all so much worse than I
remember go to starring go to starring
starring Teen Mom link twerker Bell
Buster blue the Washington DC football
team smeezy too and some little mermaids
Disney's Michael Jackson
so his name was hooked Before Peter cut
off his hand and I thought scar was a
convenient villain name
[Music]
from the author of Ricky tikki-tavi and
The White Man's Burden uh-oh comes the
animated classic that will get bare
necessity stuck in your head and have
you struggling to remember anything else
The Jungle Book before you catch the
latest live-action remake of an old
Disney classic go inside the jungle book
book movie for a barely feature-length
collection of random scenes tied
together by a plot as thin as an
orphan's loincloth as this young boy is
passed from one jokey singing animal to
another until a tiger finally shows up
and probably Burns to death the end
Journey deep into the Indian jungle
reimagine as a swing in 1960s hipster
bar to hang with a bunch of Jazzy Bebop
and animals a couple of squares and
downers and a half naked little boy that
everyone is extremely touchy with
[Music]
I know what you're trying to do give us
a smile stranger danger stranger danger
stro aimlessly along with Mowgli this
illiterate unvaccinated child who really
should have been eaten by now he's so
stubborn and Whitey you almost
understand why he got abandoned by his
parents abandoned by his wolf parents
the man cup can no longer stay with the
pack abandoned by his Panther dad from
now on you're on your own abandoned by a
troop of elephants I'll have no man Cup
in my jungle and abandoned by his
Panther dad again I give up until he
finally gets the chance to abandon them
back and do God knows what to that
little girl enjoy Disney's signature
handcrafted animation then enjoy it
again as they recycle the same shots
over and over
you can look out for yourself can you
you have the word well don't just stand
there young and helpless then recycle
them even more in other Disney movies
that's like Michael Bay lazy so forget
the blood because there isn't one and
besides you're only here for that great
song and a bunch of others you couldn't
name with a gun to your head featuring
The is this even a song song
[Music]
It's a monotone it's a boring troll
but there's no need to prolong so let's
get this boring song
time killing gibberish song
I gotta kill some screens
the touchy Uncle song
[Music]
with free candy
the weekend pork when we're older song
[Music]
alert with you from a distance till the
day that we can pour pork
and the only song that you actually
remember look Dora homeless refugees
if you don't starve you get eaten alive
yes you're a liability who almost ends
up killing me in real life I would eat
you to survive
story gemogly The Big balooski Black
Panther tiger Scar the exact same voice
as Winnie the Pooh Creepy Ride and Louis
Armstrong the jungle boar
so wait isn't this movie supposed to set
up tailspin white and blue just fly
Mowgli back home in the sea duck this
movie may have been boring but we can
all agree that talespin was freaking
awesome right
[Music]
in 1989 the same year that Taylor Swift
was born the world met an even Dilly
ride girl whose songs got even more
stuck in your head The Little Mermaid
travel under the sea to the whimsically
fascist Kingdom of Atlantica where some
fish were allowed to swim free While
others are forced to drag the ruling
class around in their chariots or use
their own bodies as instruments and meet
Ariel a half-naked 15 year old and
confirmed hoarder follow along on her
literal Fish Out of Water story as she
falls in love with the human Prince Eric
because he's hot he's very handsome
isn't he he's so beautiful the only
thing swimming in their way is the most
clearly evil villain in the Disney
Pantheon Ursula the sea witch no she's a
demon an old witch who keeps the
tortured Souls of her victims in her
front yard eat seafood and hates Ariel's
whole family but none of that will stop
Ariel from Trading away her voice for a
pair of legs in a 72-hour time limit to
French a stranger he is quite a catch
isn't he gets swept up in a Fantastical
romance where love conquers all is by
love you mean acting like a clueless
mute threat to an older guy will make
out with you and enjoy the Vintage
Disney classic with an equally vintage
message for today's young girls look
pretty you gotta look your best and you
look wonderful but without my voice how
can I you have your looks
surround yourself with friends who are
dumber and fatter than you abandon your
family to marry a guy you just met and
if you're not happy with the contract
you sign without even reading get your
fiance to murder the person who
outsmarted you
[Music]
so strap on your fins for the musical
you can't help but sing along to
featuring songs like the dumb mermaid
song I'm a dumb mermaid who doesn't know
don't know what this is or that is
either the obligatory villain saw this
boring bad guy songs so Bland so blah
but to move the plot along the villain
has to have a song but in the soundtrack
it gets scared the shouldn't you ask for
consent for a song sing with me now
foreign
[Music]
the traumatize your kid's song
[Music]
killing a fish killing fish yes we show
children this even though the heroes are
all
like if they made Sushi of Nemo and Dory
you'd have something as messed up as
these and the one we're about to get
stuck in your head it's so catchy
[Music]
until you are dead even when you sleep
he plays on repeat it's so catchy
so what the message is kind of sexiest
girls don't need brain cells just
because seashells also don't be back
[Applause]
story she's well seashells white Aladdin
Nicki Minaj fish the closest thing this
movie has to a black person Jack Gandalf
and whining Nemo the little waistline
this movie would have played out way
differently if her top half was a fish
instead
[Music]
it's a Tale As Old As Time a song as old
as rhyme an enchantress turning an 11
year old into a feral monster who 10
years later traps a girl in a castle
until she loves it
you know that Old Chestnut Beauty and
the Beast
welcome to this poor provincial French
Village where everyone has an American
accent it's not right for a woman to
read what's wrong with her she's crazy
Marie the baguette and meet Bill
daughter of the local killing machine
inventor
Bell Longs for adventure and she'll get
just that when she's kidnapped by the
Beast a prince who's so bad at his job
he's been missing for 10 years and no
one seems to notice what is this place
watch romance Bloom between her and
Prince him they never do say his name do
they in this fairy tale that teaches
every kid it's what's on the inside that
counts but it doesn't hurt to be so rich
you own a castle with its own library
and some magic slaves
cheer as this strong smart independent
woman rejects this violent controlling
bad mannered hairy dude who imprisons
her dad for this violent controlling bad
mannered hairy dude who imprisons her
dad wait why does he lock up her dad the
dude clearly wants to be left alone I'll
give you a place to stay couldn't he
just you know let him leave and get
eaten by Wolves or something that seems
a lot easier than feeding an old man for
decades
but Belle isn't alone she's trapped with
dozens of living objects that raise
dozens of uncomfortable questions like
did everything that moves used to be a
person like are all those plates people
and what happened to all the actual
stuff did it merge with the servants
will they go to trial for murdering all
those villagers that Bureau Strait of
crushes that guy if the Beast are in the
curse why did all his servants get
deformed too man this movie is messed up
so be Disney's guest at this tale as old
as Stockholm syndrome which was the
first animated feature to be nominated
for Best Picture Bud lost to a movie
with a very similar plot you will join
me for dinner it rubs the lotion on its
skin or else it gets the hose again and
managed to distract us from its messed
up story with some of Disney's most
beloved songs like the I'm too good for
this play song
[Music]
free everyone here is so lame oh my God
I can't even believe the stupid Town hey
grab it Bell good morning peasant where
are you off to the Bookshop I just
finished the most wonderful story but
you probably don't know how to read
sweet Christ you read no one cares shut
up
[Music]
the sucking yourself up song
guess he's rich and sometimes kind but
he looks like a woolly mammo shaved
behind I do love dogs but I'm not sure
that a dog man is someone I think I
could pork
the it sucks to work your song go ahead
stuff your face we are both stuck in
this place we got here with no idea we
turned into an Ikea there's no bricks
there's no pay and we're trapped in here
all day just because my boss was a deep
I become a French Candlestick
our poor friends
[Music]
I must confess we are oppressed get
snapped in half if we protest
[Music]
and the toxic relationship song Cut Her
Off from friends
and your family
throw her in a cage fly into a rage
unpredictably
[Music]
she can't get away
[Music]
she can't be released she's in constant
fear cause she's trapped in there please
call the police
starring the CrossFit bro a Pity lafoo
furry guy in a little coat Must Love
Dogs this French guy's on fire it's
always 4 35 somewhere tea she poured and
this young boy in an old man's mouth
Saved by the Bell
do I still have to sleep in the cupboard
you have 20 brothers and sisters so yeah
you probably do
[Music]
from the studio who's not exactly known
for Tastefully handling other culture
stories comes the 25th anniversary of a
middle eastern fairy tale that would
never be made today Aladdin
journey to Agrabah an ancientish arabish
land ruled under strict Sharia law do
you
do you penalties for stealing and meet
Jasmine a princess struggling with the
ultimate first world problem I don't
want to be a princess anymore she's a
strong independent woman who won't let
herself be married off like a piece of
property until she meets a sexy Bad Boy
watch her slum it up with Aladdin a
hunky Thief with no home no parents and
no nipples who steals food and gives it
to even smaller cuter orphans oh so
sweet together they'll create the most
realistic love story in Disney history
as the guy asked the girl to trust him
do you trust me do you trust me then
says whatever it takes to get into her
MC Hammer pants tell her that
and at the end of it all must face the
consequences of his pathological lying
by getting everything he ever wanted
sit back as Robin Williams takes over
the film as the magical genie who's so
powerful he does impressions of people
who won't be born for hundreds of years
it's ever impressive I can't believe it
I'm losing to a rug right here for you
very much wish fulfillment all right
Sparky here's the deal I can't bring
people back from the dead kids just love
a good Peter Lori enjoy his non-stop
improvise Rippy that made him
everybody's favorite part of the film
and every Disney animator's worst
nightmare the exits are here here here
here here anywhere oh they're poor poor
hands conspiring against them is Jafar
who's goatee black robes and snake staff
should really tip people off that he's
evil a princess will marry me
and his accomplice Iago I can't take it
anymore he was now the second most
famous bird Gilbert Gottfried has ever
voiced I've
follow along on an adventure that made
people spend way too much time thinking
about what they'd spend their three
wishes on and taught kids that it's not
how rich you are but what's inside that
counts if by inside you mean inside a
magical lamp that can make you rich so
get ready for a movie that if it weren't
for the genie in the music would be
pretty by the numbers but man is that
Genie funny and man is that music good
featuring Unforgettable songs like the
narrator song
credits will go much faster you know so
the young kids won't bear the telling
kids it's okay to steal song ceiling
it's fine if you need it get yours
forget the police feed me or I will
disturb the peace
that's how cartoon bread straws the take
your kid to the bathroom song time to
pee nothing to see or at least
wash your hands zip up your pants you
can trust me
Aladdin's turn to a prince don't worry
it'll make sense no need to whine
anymore your kid can pee
napping your dates on I just kidnapped
this girl
cause her midriff is sexy we are up here
now let's see if she'll rub my lamp
tonight I'll pork biscuit
as long as that's okay with you
no creepy long face dude or family feuds
to keep us both from
corkyard
can watch us too even though you're a
fraud I like that bud so I'll enjoy an
Airborne pork with you are so much
and the Robin Williams song
without his mask
[Music]
the torch can pass for Henry cast but
I'll always be the best always be the
basketball remake talk arrest either be
a mess cause I'll always be the best
you ain't never gonna recast me
story a liar
Blue Jasmine
Maleficent the original Angry Bird
curious Abu the hardest level in the
Super Nintendo game really ties the room
together and Robin's screen time a genie
that Jasmine is so hot right guys maybe
the hottest Disney princess ever well
guess what she's 15 years old don't you
feel gross now well at least it's okay
for Aladdin to uh oh
foreign
[Music]
director Tim Burton I mean from writer
Tim Burton with music and lyrics by Tim
Burton no well what did he do Tim
Burton's The Nightmare Before Christmas
[Music]
suit up for a heartwarming holiday
classic full of incredible animation
amazing songs and haunting visuals that
makes every emo kid feel special and
unique even though they're all in love
with the same movie oh journey to a
magical forest where inside each tree
lies a world dedicated to a single
holiday except for all the Jewish ones
and discover Halloweentown a land that
exists just to throw one party a year
there's only 365 days left till next
Halloween and the rest of the time
rehearses their big dance number I guess
meet Jack the Pumpkin King a menorexic
skeleton when he tires of his life of
Fame and Fortune he'll set off on a
Grand Adventure of cultural
appropriation but you're the Pumpkin
King not anymore as he hijacks Christmas
traumatizes children
and lets a demon have his way with Santa
Claus what are you going to do
the best I can yeah see this is what
happens when you take Jesus out of
Christmas
experience a Whimsical one-sided romance
between Jack and your first goth Crush
Sally a suicidal cutter who can't stop
Roofing her dad that's twice this month
you've slipped deadly nightshade into my
tea and run off three times she'll Pine
to jump Jack's bones even though he
never listens to a word she says until
they randomly fall in love and live
happily ever after the end seriously the
movie's like an hour long there's really
not that much to it
so enjoy this short but sweet film that
launched an entire genre of creepy
stop-motion kids movies that we mostly
remember for its gorgeous score in
catchy music with Unforgettable songs
like the is this a Halloween or
Christmas movie song what's this what's
this is this a Christmas flick what's
this then why the spooky stick what's
this like Gremlins or Die Hard is kind
of both things hey just pick one and
commit what's this
[ __ ]
is it Christmas or is it Halloween it's
mixed take one look at this scene you
see the streets are light with toys and
happy children but I looked like I might
kill them how could you think so
Divergent coexist screw this and The
Perennial classic the we keep Hot Topic
in business song
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
starring Slenderman Hell in a cotton
Carter a two-faced politician oh I see
what you did there duck man remember
Duck man rudog the dead-nosed reindeer
and evil laundry A Christmas Story
that seems terrifying but at least we
know from the black lights that there's
no uh DNA on Santa uh I've got to stop
watching this for you
[Music]
before they was frozen relive the peak
of Disney Animation followed immediately
by its downfall
[Music]
The Lion King
revisit the original tale of a royal air
whose parents die prompting them to run
away from their Kingdom then sing a song
about letting go of their worries while
Things Fall Apart back home and return
to defeat an evil Prince
I knew there was a reason I liked that
movie
the journey to Pride Rock an animal
kingdom with some incredibly generous
borders everything the light touches is
our kingdom and its own version of New
Jersey what about that shadowy place
let's never go there Simba where all of
its African animals talk like they're
British good morning sir evil British
it's to die for
Latino que pasa
so where you from gangster damn ain't no
way I'm going in there or CNN
witness the birth of Lion King Simba an
obnoxious know-it-all who rubs his
privilege in everyone's face my dad just
showed me the whole Kingdom and I'm
gonna rule it all watches Simba's life
of leisure is Shattered by his evil
Uncle a lion who is either named scar by
coincidence or he got stuck with a
really mean nickname get ready for a
G-rated movie filled with domestic abuse
I'm 10 times
a child raised by a same-sex couple not
that there's a problem with that and the
most traumatic death of a parent since
Bambi's mom got shot in the face Dad
we gotta go home
Hakuna Matata
so let Frozen go and experience the best
music of any Disney musical ever with
Unforgettable songs like they'll be
careful what you wish for song
[Music]
the plotting evil stuff song
so prepare because I am the bad guy be
prepared
I think
I'd be the catchy song to distract kids
from the horrific death they just saw I
went through foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but now it's time
[Music]
and the song that pulls us into thinking
these animals live in harmony
without words
but he could
either
but to remind us
story lion Jafar bird Sebastian Ren and
stippy Ed Edd and Eddy do me eyes dad
Vader and Kimba the White Lion seriously
look it up The Lion King
wait if mufas and Scar the only male
lions in the pride then Nala's dad is
probably oh no
this summer we're getting honest about
summer Blockbusters past and present
this is Honest Trailers Blockbuster
summer
now that you've finished the Mandalorian
on Disney plus given up on Artemis Fowl
after 10 minutes and puts animation on
in the background while you text
it's time to squeeze the last bit of
value out of your seven bucks a month by
revisiting the low budget spin-off of a
syndicated Disney Afternoon show
that clocks in under 80 minutes with
credits it is one of the best films of
an otherwise soft era for the Big D
sorry dinosaur at least you only cost
well 127 million in 20 years ago money
alrighty then
A Goofy Movie
welcome to the world of goofy where the
finisher fish the birds are birds and
everyone else is somewhere on the
spectrum between dog cat and man where
you'll see slapstick Legend goofy like
you've never seen them before a Suburban
dad desperately trying to connect with a
son who hates him what the heck you
trying to do trying to get away from you
what kind of hooked up kids movie is
this
[Laughter]
every teenager thinks their parents are
the most embarrassing people in the
world but only goofy son Max can make a
solid case for it
he's out to ditch his dad and get with
Roxanne a girl he's never spoken to she
finally says hi to me but puts on a
pedestal and is so thirsty for he
literally sees her in the water can't
blame him 90s where a golden age for
animated love interests together this
Goof Troop will set off on a road trip
across a post-apocalyptic mirror
Dimension that's geographically
identical to our own and Bun as they
narrowly avoid committing vehicular
homicides
[Music]
kill a mine
and rescue Max's best friend from his
abusive Dad if my dad catches me with
this he'll kill me if my dad finds out
he's gonna nuke my entire existence my
dad is gonna smash me like a bug uh oh
in a film that teaches us the importance
of clear and honest father-son
communication but since it has the same
screenwriter as Aladdin it also teaches
us how lying to girls just makes them
like you more I really am a prince
my dad
um No No's power line oh yuck off
so buckle up for the Disney adventure
with the biggest heart and the lowest
Stakes where instead of rescuing a
kingdom or breaking an ancient curse the
hero must endure spending time with an
actually alive parent speaking of which
where is Max's mom Anyway full of
amazing songs from Tevin Campbell as
Powerline
skippable songs from goofy do you long
to shed your weary load and the exact
amount of poly Shore before it gets
obnoxious look it's the leaning tower of
Jesus
that's it stop right there perfect not a
second more
story
the Dog Father Little Bow Wow diddly who
neighborino wait his name is PJ Pete
Pete Jr Pete and his dad is Pete Pete
out of their civilization last this long
Kelly kapupsky skipping school
inconceivable geez the Jews and all dogs
flow to Tevin
Mad Max furry road trip
so are we going to talk about how
they're being followed by nuns
everywhere they go
[Music]
from the studio that dominated the early
90s with the little mermaid Beauty and
the Beast and Aladdin comes an absolute
stinker that kicked off more than a
decade of garbage Pocahontas
Mead Pocahontas a product of Disney's
underage thirst trap era she's a
princess based on a real 12 year old sex
trafficking victim transformed into a
dry land version of Ariel I expect those
rules to be obeyed you disobeyed me
daddy I love him I love him father in
this all Leg Adventure that's just a
little mermaid without the catchy songs
sense of fun or knowledge that they're
all about to die from war feminine
disease but uh look over there
pretty waterfalls
when you need an Australian to play an
Englishman who sounds like an American
to patronize an Indian you call Mel
Gibson we've improved the lives of
savages all over the world Savages he'll
play John Smith a guy as bland is the
name John Smith would imply I'm John
Smith watch this Explorer discover he
has so much in common with Pocahontas
they're both hot their eyebrows don't
match their hair color
and that's it as these two characters as
thin and two-dimensional as the cells
they were painted on find love during
the time of colonization a big goof up
with plenty of good people on both sides
once two sides want to fight nothing can
stop them in fact the English would be
friendly if it wasn't for One Bad Apple
in this historical epic that teaches us
all the real colonizer was love all
along London is that your village yes
buildings as tall as trees I'd like to
see those things see there she didn't
have to be kidnapped back to London who
said anything about her being kidnapped
if I don't look it up it's like it never
happened
when you're not stuck wasting time with
Pocahontas enjoy your time with equally
boring Side characters like three animal
Sidekicks more bumming than Bob chayback
[Music]
a talking tree that's a little too
thorned up for Comfort I want to see him
again I want to see him again and he's
handsome too and a bunch of English
explorers who unfortunately weren't lost
at sea in the opening scene not a
thousand bloodthirsty Savages shall
stand in our way if any Indian tries to
stop me they'll blast him Savages could
be hiding anywhere do you think we need
some Savages these white men are
dangerous
so this Thanksgiving revisit an animated
musical whose songs range from
forgettable
too regrettable
or maybe two or three except for one
absolute Jam about how indigenous folks
are mythical beings with magical powers
instead of actual people who still exist
think my tribe are Ordinary People
and claim a land you think you can
explain
but we are all imbued with superpowers
we know magic we are Druids I'm
amazed I'm basically an X-Man or Avenger
the Heron and the order I command
and if you cross me John you will
discover
I can walk into Morgan's Bird that's on
my hand and
they never hear your voice cry while the
End come soon when I just shut the
payback for your skins I could blow you
from this Lion King as Mountain I
control the ancient forces of the wind
if you cross me then I will grind your
bones to dust until
you're just pieces
I can scatter
in
[Music]
with
[Music]
story
The Maze Runner
Porta John
90-day financier trash Bandicoot
Colonial American Psycho Mr Smee Chief
of Staff it's Giving Tree Wizards of the
Coast
and exactly what TLC warned us not to do
love at first White
[Music]
going back is his only chance he'll die
if he stays here so it ends with Jon
heading back to England to treat his
gunshot wound by boat is anyone gonna
tell him
well Disney may be able to change their
release schedule but it's now or nothing
for us let's move it
[Music]
from the studio that brought you the we
are siamese song
[Music]
Donald Duck's unfortunate World War II
Adventures Japanese Customs say always
shooting a man in the back please and an
Asian cat playing piano with chopsticks
off comes their stab and a Chinese folk
tale about gender roles now that's what
I call Mongolian Barbecue uh-oh Mulan
before you see Disney's first actually
justifiable live-action remake someday
revisit the first time the mouse gave
this story the Disney treatment by
smushing hundreds of years of unrelated
Chinese history together jamming awkward
90cg into beautiful 2D animation and
cutting between a Grim War Story and the
fast talking hijinks of a G-rated Eddie
Murphy what's your name
I killed myself that was funny now back
to the death how many men does it take
to to deliver a message one meet Mulan
she's got the classic pretty princess
problem where she knows there's more to
life than this but where most princesses
think they need a man Mulan will cut out
the middleman and instead she'll just be
a man and while she's more inclined to
hug the patriarchy then smash it she
will kill a lot more dudes with snow
than Elsa ever dreamed of
holy crap this girl's got a body count
that could fill the Matterhorn but Mulan
isn't alone in her fight against the
Huns an evil race complete with fangs
claws yellow beady eyes and good Lord
Disney these were an actual people
another urukai she'll be joined by Mushu
a tiny dragon workshopping his donkey
audition hey dragon dragon dragon
and a Supporting Cast that's also
challenging stereotypes a gentle giant a
cricket who doesn't wear hats are seeing
and a Chinese guy who sounds just like
Harvey firesty I am worth my time hey in
the 90s this is what progress looked
like at least he's not playing piano
with the Chopsticks always wrong don't
show it again but this kid's flick isn't
on Warren wieners
foreign
the handsome Captain with the body of an
Adonis and the vocal chops of a Donny
Osmond
he's a little pink curious a little
Mulan Furious and very very shirtless
creating a passionate fan base that
demands an answer to just one thing you
have my trust
why does Lee have nipples when Aladdin
doesn't a little nip consistency is all
we're asking for here at least make them
an option on Disney Plus
so suda for a Disney movie that much
like its Heroes has struggled with its
identity because it was too American for
Chinese audiences too conservative for
Lee Shang fans and way too liberal for
vice president Mike Pence but it still
found its place in the Disney Pantheon
thanks to its bold heroine Charming
comedy and a few memorable songs like
the stereotypically Chinese song racism
the glorified chant masquerading as a
song song
[Music]
[Music]
the no time to explain but Mulan can
fight now song
[Music]
still weak
cue the training montage
[Music]
for that's what songs like this one are
good
and the Not So subtle coming out song
again
I gave us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stirring
lulana man dracaurus is my name I like
the way you work it no Germany Shang
sings in 1992 Chen you was an
advertising executive in Baltimore
Maryland then for reasons known only to
him he left his wife in Korea and moved
deep into the forest now he's only known
as the falconer
realizing you got Mulan to thank for
Rick and Morty's worst fans
McDonald's is offering tender crispy
chicken McNuggets and a new Szechuan
sauce for a taste of the East Big
Trouble in actual China
stop cheering you're gonna get bits of
fun in your mouth
[Music]
after huge bombs like Atlantis the Lost
Empire and Treasure Planet but before a
huge bomb like Brother Bear came Disney
animations last hiccup of success before
Bob Iger said screw this let's just buy
Pixar Lilo and Stitch return to the era
of flat 2D animation that in this
movie's case is still full of Curves
everything has kind of a roundness
that's puffed up a little bit for
instance legs are bottom heavy they're
chunkier at the bottom and meat Stitch a
biological weapon on a five-star GTA
crime spree he's taken a police cruiser
he's not just insanely violent
[Music]
hey
he's not just profoundly disgusting
no worst of all he speaks like the love
child of Gollum and a minions
[Music]
Two Worlds will collide when Stitch
meets Lilo and Nani the saddest family
unit in Disney history we're a broken
family aren't we Lilo is friendless and
poor trying to please a fish who she
thinks controls the weather because her
parents were killed in a storm it was
rainy and they went for a drive Nani is
a constantly unemployed teenager raising
her sister whose only friend is trying
to get in her pants Oh David I owe you
one you can just date me and we'll call
it even and they're both being stalked
by the world's most Relentless Child
Protective Services agent did you ever
kill anyone we're getting off the
subject wow that's Grimm still not as
Grim as whatever's going on in this dog
shelter what is that thing a dog I think
but it was dead this morning then why
was he in the same cage as the living
dogs you freak through as our heroes are
pursue sued by a blatant rip-off of the
Federation from Star Trek Captain
with a slightly more LAX policy on
global genocide we have to guess the
planet when Stitch escapes they'll
deputize one wacky waving inflatable
arms Tube Man and one guy with a Russian
accent so you just know he's evil hiding
behind your little friend won't work
anymore to put on objectively terrible
disguises go on a hilarious attempted
murder spree you're mine
then abandon their mission to join the
heroes at the end because because
because the movie is 90 minutes long and
Pixar's Riders aren't there to help out
yet you expect me to help you just like
that
fun so enjoy one of the underappreciated
jams of Disney's past that made a few
much needed changes to the formula
swapping original songs for Elvis
fantasy locales for the real Hawaii and
an ending that mimicked the 911
hijackings for one that didn't
that change makes sense but what's up
with the Disney plus version turning the
dryer into a pizza storage shelf back in
my day we played in the dryer and we
liked it wee
story
Fight Club
Molly never skipped leg day Dexter
jetster's laboratory pleakly fly day
Ving rings as himself Hunka Burning Love
and his captain getting too hot or have
we been in lockdown for way too long
Galaxy passed
three days ago I got stitched at the
shelter I paid two dollars for him see
the snap I own them sorry Lilo perhaps
you should read the fine print next time
this is just a thank you letter to the
Animation Studios for their work on this
movie take them away boys
foreign
Disney spent years working on a classic
2D animated Rapunzel movie but when
Princess and the Frog plopped and Shrek
sword to box up his Heights King Eisner
decreed they start over with a joke
filled CGI ROM for girls and boys alike
and you know what it's better than
Frozen come at me haters
Tangled
enjoy another fairy tale where they eat
the parents before our story even begins
and meet Rapunzel a beautiful hostage
with 70 feet of magic hair not only can
It Grant eternal life it doesn't even
get nasty after dragging it through the
forest follow along with this weird
overeager homeschooled kid who really
wants to see the Kingdom's annual fire
hazard for her birthday I want to see
the floating lights but everything will
change when she tries to kill a handsome
Intruder and hide his corpse in a closet
she'll fall for Flynn Ryder hi a Playboy
with a mean case of DreamWorks face and
Flynn's just one of the narcissists
taking advantage of the magic shut-in as
Rapunzel is under the spell of her witch
mother goggle wait is she a witch or is
Disney just conditioned me to think
every childless older woman is evil
anywho she'll use the powers of guilt
shame and gaslighting to stop her barely
legal daughter from running off with a
26 year old career criminal and gets
murdered by a chameleon for her troubles
and that's we're not letting her marry
literally the first guy she's ever met
which everyone watch a man fight a horse
a lot
squeal with Glee at a B story ripped
straight from a tech Savory cartoon
as Maximus the horse cops talks playing
like the Terminator and continues the
grand animation tradition of turning
every animal's sidekick no matter what
species into a dog you're such a good
boy
sit whoa stay
oh
isn't that right AC happy to see you too
buddy
sing along to a film that sort of gives
up on being a musical halfway through
featuring half an album's worth of Alan
Menken b-sides that still manages to hit
the four main genres of Disney song
joyfully going about your daily routine
I play guitar
[Music]
I'm an obvious villain pretending to be
your best friend mother knows best take
it from your mouth
I'm a tough guy revealing my soft side
Causeway numb deep inside I've got a
dream
foreign
[Music]
we didn't make parodies for these you
have to know the original sport to work
go ahead on the tune to Healing
incantation I'll wait so embark on a new
Disney classic that's Charming funny and
romantic throughout except for the
nonsensical ending where tears can
suddenly heal the sick that is unless
you're familiar with the source material
where Rapunzel's tears cure blindness
since her prince gouge his own eyes out
after throwing himself off the tower in
despair now that's a grim fairy tale
story
Golden Girl Harry Potter Joey Tribbiani
how you doing coaching Gorge cartoon
cartoon
chameleon knobs and Shaw and my name is
Maximus horsidius Steve to Echidna
princess servant to the true king and I
will have my Vengeance in this life or
the next
[Music]
oh a young blonde girl with a wreath in
her hair takes a birthday trip with her
Shady boyfriend to witness an annual
ritual hmm anyone else getting strong
mid-summer Vibes here
foreign
[Music]
you've seen toys come to life in Toy
Story ghost is Claire now kick your
children's paranoia into overdrive with
the exact same premise but for video
games all clear the arcade's clothes
Wreck-It Ralph travel to a fantasy world
where video game characters interact
with each other and an even bigger
fantasy where kids leave the house for
some place called an arcad or caddy
instead of yelling racial swords at each
other on Xbox Live In This Charming
dystopia where living feeling game
characters spend their lives trapped in
an endless cycle of violence we've only
been plucked in a week and every day
it's climbed the building then fight
bugs climb the building fight more bugs
yikes now I feel really bad for the guys
inside Dark Souls get ready for all your
dad slash owner Brothers favorite gaming
franchises to join forces on the big
screen in teeny tiny cameos and
extremely subtle references
while you spend most of your time with
weird hybrid characters because Disney
couldn't get the rights to Donkey Kong
master chief or Mario but they had
plenty left in the budget for Qbert
and uh Tapper
hang on a second you had the rise to
Sonic the Hedgehog and you made Tapper
main character meet Sarah Silverman an
incorrigible PG version of Sarah
Silverman
who is secretly a princess because
Disney can't be too far off brand she'll
race down the path of self-acceptance
with the help of Wreck-It Ralph a bad
guy who's tired of being bad I don't
want to be the bad guy anymore who runs
away to become a good guy I could be a
good guy if I wanted to which is bad for
these good guys but when our good bad
guy realizes being bad is good if he's
bad for good reasons he can save the
good guys from the real bad guy by being
good at being bad I'm bad
and that's good
I will never be good and that's not bad
it's not as bad as it sounds when fate
brings these two Misfits together
they'll journey across an arcade full of
possible game worlds yet only spend time
in two of them Hero's Duty a two dollar
a pop shooter on Rails that's over in
like 30 seconds and Sugar Rush a candy
coated Mario Kart with so many candy
puns he will swear the first draft was
for a Candyland movie milk my Duds
they're Laffy Taffy oh you're the guy
that makes the donuts call Out the Devil
Dogs
quicksand you need to rotten little
cavities Children of the Candy Corn
I'm hungry wasn't this movie about video
games so revisit this adorable animated
Adventure that finally cracked how to
make a good video game movie by not
focusing too much on the video games and
just like Toy Story uses bright colors
and fast pacing to distract you from its
horrifying existential questions like if
everyone lives in the surge protector
what happens if it gets turned off what
if they plug something else in would the
games be able to go into a microwave are
there different routes in different
arcades what if an arcade has to Fix It
Felix games are they all going through
the same mid-life crisis do game
programmers know what they're doing to
their Creations she's programmed with
the most tragic backstory ever isn't it
dark that every game character is
terrified of breaking the status quo
lest it bring instant death from an
uncaring God will be put out of order
for God
and what the hell video game is Skrillex
from Starry Kong C Riley Sarah Sugarman
repair man man gamer Gates worst
nightmare and for the love of God don't
Google Sonic fan art
pixels
if Ralph really wanted to get things
done he should have just brought Kano
along
Kano wins
[Music]
from the studio that finally learned how
to make Pixar movies and the songwriting
Duo behind Hasa Diga eebowai comes the
feature-length music video for Let It Go
Frozen
it's been three years since the last
Disney musical and 18 years since the
last good Disney musical now the Big D
is back and adjusted for inflation with
two princesses two goopy side gigs and
three different orphans welcome to
Arendelle a magical-ish scandinavian-ish
country that's been cursed with eternal
winter even though their main export is
ice meet Elsa a manic depressive
princess with a confusing set of powers
like snow blasting dressmaking castle
building and creating life you're alive
um I think so they kind of gloss over
that one
fall in love with her adorkable sister
Anna who spends three years of her adult
life shut inside a castle even though
she could leave at any time
I get this anymore then leave and who
could forget the completely unnecessary
unexplained magical troll rocks when
disaster strikes watch Anna save the day
by teaming up with her sister a merchant
a hot guy and a snowman to defeat
villains like her sister a merchant a
hot guy and a snowman experience a
clever Twist on past Disney films that
teaches girls everywhere they don't need
a prince to rescue them because all men
are disgusting loners greedy murderers
or lying manipulative power-hungry
sociopaths you won't get away with this
I already have happy now Jezebel
so gather the family and sing along on a
musical Journey that's all about the
soundtrack featuring Unforgettable songs
like the exposition song do you want
some Exposition
some information through Us song
the song that sounds like it's from
Wicked
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
For The First Time in Forever
it's as good as Lion King
the Romantic duet
the other romantic duet I'm kinda turned
on by reindeer
[Music]
the anthropomorphic Sidekicks comic
relief song when you're out of ideas you
give them a singing Snowman
the one you skip
[Music]
the one you don't know the words
[Music]
and the YOLO song
[Music]
get it out get it out
[Music]
[Applause]
starring forgotten Sarah Marshall
Kristoff Waltz
ugly Smurfs Hans Gruber merchandising
and the wickedly talented Adele diseem
Frozen
you don't need true love to thaw a
frozen heart just soak it in water for a
few hours works on turkeys
[Music]
before you see the latest CGI kids movie
that adults will probably get more out
of revisit the Disney hit that made you
laugh cry won an Oscar and best of all
isn't Frozen Big Hero 6. prepare for a
movie based on a Marvel comic you had no
idea existed that Disney removed all the
Marvel branding from and didn't tie into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe despite
the fact that it has a team of quippy
Heroes going up against a forgettable
villain with a vague plan in a final
battle with the sky-based doomsday
device made of disposable robots and an
after credit scene with Stan Lee I mean
come on this is The Marvelous non-marvel
movie ever journey to a way less foggy
slightly more Asian version of San
Francisco and meet Baymax an adorable
combination of WebMD and a marshmallow
he's the inflatable Robo nurse everyone
wants to cuddle with Until you realize
he's voiced by the depressed middle-aged
comedy writer from 30 Rock 2. watch
Baymax team up with a super orphan hero
hero hero hero hero hero is a hero or
hero hero hero hero
hero hero my name is hero whatever he's
a protagonist with the hair of a
Japanese anime and the tooth gap of
every kid from recent western animation
thrill as this miniature version of Tony
Stark makes inventions that will put
everyone on Earth out of a job what used
to take teams of people months or years
can now be accomplished by one person
and immediately transforms his inherited
Healthcare robot it killing machine I
failed to see how karate makes me a
better healthcare companion punch this
it's like Terminator 2 but in Reverse
after the Sci-Fi pessimism of Wally
experience a Kids film that's so into
science it turns it into magic justified
by the tiniest bit of scientific
mumbo-jumbo
electromag suspension magnetic bearing
servos laser induced plasma chemical
metal embrittlement yeah
um when guardium Leviosa and watch as
these Scrappy college kids create
billion dollar inventions and get
rewarded with dinner dinner is gone yes
nothing is better than free food just
like the NCAA
experience a moving film about the power
of friendship forgiveness and Innovation
until it turns into a cookie cutter
superhero origin story you guys do you
feel this are origin story begins with a
dumb Scooby-Doo twist and a Supporting
Cast that's literally forgettable hey
but maybe don't leave your team stranded
on a Spooky Island next time oh man but
who cares baymax is bae still enjoy
another entry in what might be a new
Disney animated Renaissance that takes
the cold emotionless fields of science
and engineering and transforms them into
a heartwarming tale with the power of
hugs Luts and lots of hugs it's like
spooning a warm marshmallow going for a
non-threatening huggable kind of thing
last hug last hug if I could have only
one superpower right now it would be the
ability to crawl through this camera and
give you a big hug
story Obamacare hero is it me you're
looking for a TJ Miller type human
Segway dreadlock Silo April o' nerd gag
and spooky Legos
the incredit wings
does this symbol mean anything to you
guys we're getting another Hunger Games
[Music]
when Disney slapped Frozen's name in a
short film to squeeze more cash out of
their biggest hit Honest Trailers had
the perfect excuse to slap Frozen's name
on a video to squeeze more views out of
our biggest hit Frozen fever
remember Frozen sort it right since the
Big D couldn't make a sequel quickly
enough prepare for a glorified music
video that's trying to beat the clock
before your kids grow out of their
Frozen face now available on Blu-ray for
20 bucks no that is it Daddy is done
spending money on this Frozen crap
stop crying we're poor now remember
Standalone Princess toys like Cinderella
Snow White and Sleeping Beauty Disney
doesn't as we shamelessly return to
Arendale for less time than it takes to
listen to Freebird all your favorite
characters are back in the exact same
locations to cut down on costs and
rendering time as Elsa leads you by a
string on a tour of various Frozen
merchandise full of not so subtle
callbacks to the original movie and
catchphrases so forced they would make
Schwarzenegger blush I don't get colds
besides a cold never bothered me anyway
witness the exact moment when the
filmmakers gave up on having Elsa's ice
powers make any kind of sense in a scene
where she can move flowers with her mind
change the color of people's clothing
and create out of control ravenous
sentient life forms proving once and for
all that Arendale will be a safer place
if they lock this dangerous witch up in
her ice tower
she's a menace so experience Frozen
without the story stupid troll Rock
thingies or good music featuring one
long rambling tune that definitely won't
take the place of Let It Go
wait wait stop the music don't even
bother we're not singing this one you
probably haven't heard it anyway
Story the following reasons Disney needs
to keep frozen relevant an upcoming
Broadway show a new theme park Olaf duct
tape but wives tiny Jeep Wranglers
chicken soup perfume multivitamins
bullying personal checks this weird
styling head and horrifying snow cone
machines you do realize you're eating
Olaf's intestines while he watches right
Frozen reminder
do you remember when Disney actually
tried to hide the innuendos in their
films because those things look like
chubby little dicks
[Music]
from pixney I mean Disney man these two
are really starting to blend together
comes the Disney animated film that
grossed a billion dollars and finally
got people to stop talking about Frozen
Let It Go zootopia journey to zootopia a
place with 12 unique ecosystems and one
generic pop song in this city that's
either an impossibly advanced Paradise
where animals live together in harmony
or a Palace built by our mammal
overlords in the ashes of our extinct
human world after war and famine wiped
us from the earth you know one of the
two fall in love with smart complex
animal characters in their lazy forced
pun names his name is Emmett otterton
it's weaselton Joe quaselton mayor
Lionheart Benjamin clawhauser like Judy
Hobbs get it cause she's
Cinema's most likable meter made
actually Cinema's only likable being
raid because seriously meter maids are
the worst I mean come on I was only in
there for like five minutes and no you
haven't written a little ticket yet
because they can see your stupid little
machine right there get a real job lady
my mommy said she wishes you were dead
so do I
together man win hops teams up with foxy
con artist Nick Wilde they'll work
together to catch more Predators than
Chris Hanson and form a sort of romance
you know you love me do I know that
yes yes I did that sadly they'll never
be able to consummate not because I'm
speciesist or anything it's just that
nobody in this movie has any genitals or
even a you know a butthole seriously how
does anyone even go to the bathroom in
this place follow along with his kids
film slash Noir crime Thriller full of
bright colors cute characters allegories
to contemporary racial and class
politics you're not like them oh there's
a them now police discrimination you
think I'm gonna believe a fox
affirmative action mammal inclusion
initiative tokenism sir I'm not just
some token bunny sexism so are all
rabbits bad drivers or is it just you
and racial slurs a bunny can call
another bunny cute but when other
animals it has a little they will either
teach your kid to be more tolerant or
turn them into a furry so settle in for
a fantastically animated well-toed
lesson about disproving stereotypes even
though the fox character really is
sneaky the weasels do cheat and the
sloths are slow oh wait no does this
mean I'm racist I owned a bunch of
rabbits when I was a kid I mean no they
were mine not that I you know not let
their property or look I love rabbits
okay this they came out all wrong go to
starring go to starring starring NYPD
Blues the part in the trailer that made
you want to see the movie Buffalo
bad mayor Mufasa Shakira and Shakira
your stereotypical Italian mobster your
stereotypical donut eating cob your
stereotypical dumb Southerner and hot
Buzz he get it cause she's a bunny cop
but she's hot too wait I could say that
she's hot though right dang it am I a
racist Anna furry now oh this movie is
such a mind field paw and Order
let's see Pig Hero 6 wrangled record
Rhino I wonder what they think of Lion
King in The Jungle Book are they like
documentaries
[Music]
are you ready for a new kind of Disney
movie full of strong female characters
no forced romantic subplots and a
celebration of Polynesian culture then
you'll love
Lilo and Stitch did not see that coming
oh and probably also Moana
meet Moana a strong determined young
woman who won't stop until she gets the
job done I am Moana you will board my
boat they'll across the sea and restore
the heart of te fiti who after 90
minutes of Adventure becomes a strong
determined young woman who won't stop
until she gets the job done I am Moana
you were born my vote sail across the
sea and restore the heart of tefiti
she's indestructible
she's fearless and she's got water
powers just as confusing and vague as
Elsa's ice magic and Frozen so wait does
she even have any water powers at all or
does it only protect Whoever has the
glowy thing and if the ocean has her
back why does he keep trying to drown
her
follow along on moana's quest to save
her Homeland by following a super
obvious sign Maui lies there in a
journey that pokes fun at all of
Disney's usual tropes if you wear a
dress and you have an animal sidekick
you're a princess if you start singing
I'm gonna throw up well at the same time
being 100 guilty of them from her cute
animal Sidekicks to her grand Mufasa to
her Genie Maui an all-powerful
charismatic brawling tattoo demigod so
pretty much the Rock
enjoy the highest honor a culture can
receive these days having your
Traditions commodified by the Disney
Corporation and watch as the Polynesian
people who travel between islands
thousands of miles apart thousands of
years ago are represented by paranoid
coconut lovers who would rather starve
to death and sail past a three-foot
break we were voyagers we get Voyage
again
how lay for effort I guess
so enjoy a film with a soundtrack people
can't stop gushing about because the guy
from Hamilton is involved and not even
the ocean gushes as hard as Hamilton
fans featuring songs like the they're
really into Coconut song
[Music]
Where You Are but hey
[Music]
your memory a coconut when you turn 13.
[Music]
oh we're making the rock sing song you
can smell what I'm cooking I'll save
your franchise make money no problem you
all recognize my voice my five
[Music]
auto-tune couldn't get me on track I'll
be president someday still I can't sing
but who else pulls off a fanny pack
to Let It Go a song
for Disney they told me
to sing a club
[Music]
and the Beautiful song in a foreign
language that could be saying anything
song
hello hello
I hope you like that one because it
turns out it's really freaking hard to
find a Toki Loudoun translator starring
Nemo choking the chicken David glowy shy
guys and wow Troy Polamalu really let
himself go Pacific swim
okay so wait a second Rapunzel has demon
hair Elsa has ice powers and Moana is a
water bender are we building up to
Disney's Princess Avengers
[Music]
from the studio who brought you Lion
King one and a half Mulan two and lady
in the [ __ ] two scams adventure comes a
Disney animated film that's nothing like
their lazy director video sequels of the
past because this one came out in
theaters
Frozen two
six years after Frozen melted your heart
you grew up and moved on to better
things but when there's money to be made
some companies just can't let it go in
this scatter shot follow-up wrapped
around an album's worth of b-sides
that's vague and World building enough
to set the stage for Frozen's three
through seven and a half scamps
Adventure that was epic all your
favorite characters are back to who they
were at the beginning of Frozen one Elsa
still moping on balconies Anna still
caught between her sister and a mister
Kristoff has so little to do they give
him the pot of a 1930s comedy act I said
you'd have to be crazy to want to marry
a man you just met wait what crazy you
didn't say I was crazy you think I'm
crazy no and Olaf is doing his best to
hold it all together until he joins the
Disney Hall of dust
but what they all lack in character
growth they make up for a costume
upgrades mom I already told you I want
to sell my choice Elsa with the sparkly
personal growth dress this is fearless
Queen Elsa with a customer dream Cape
idiot and where's new permafrost Olaf
are you ready to set up on a quest to
discover the dark secret of Arendale not
so fast first listen to this bedtime
story and then a lullaby there's a river
then get a Grime song stuck in your head
foreign
just kind of meets up for a hang then a
song about how every minute brings us
closer to death and we're all getting
older then wow we're still not up in a
quest yet okay I guess we have time for
a full game of Charades then just one
more lullaby please
and now we'll set off in a quest whew
Frozen one managed to fit all the plot
and character set up into one song with
time left over to Build a Snowman when
our heroes finally get their ices in
gear they'll go explore the Enchanted
Forest known as the Enchanted Forest a
hidden world full of cutting-edge
particle effects and dough rejects from
Avatar The Last Airbender there they'll
learn the Dark Truth About Arendale long
ago they betrayed the indigenous people
to the north and by long ago I mean
Grandpa did it grandfather but if you
think this is setting up some hard
choices or sacrifice or even commentary
on historical Injustice it isn't
everything's just fine who else was in
on the pot did the people to the north
want revenge shut up Elsa's got a water
horse now
so strap in for a brand new Frozen that
could get sued by Thor Ragnarok if
Disney didn't already own everything we
do this together okay has no one been
taught our history Odin and I drowned
entire civilizations in Blood and Tears
but that goes against everything
Arendelle stands for made of rocks as
you can see it seems to know it's less
interesting or fun than the first one so
most of the runtime is spent reminiscing
about it
when you pretend to be Kristoff and
you're like I just need to go talk to
some rocks about my childhood I climbed
to the North Mountain survived a frozen
heart and saved you from my ex-boyfriend
two sisters one born with magical powers
one born poundless what did happen to
your parents the ship went down in the
Southern Sea six years ago
Do You Want to Build a Snowman and if
you're expecting song parodies at this
point inspiration didn't really strike
twice for this movie and it didn't for
us either so just go scream into the
unknown as loud as you can until you
pass out you get the gist
oh
story
Frosty the sidekick the last black man
in Arendale
they look like big strong hands don't
they toothless Norwegian Rhapsody the
best friend from a rom-com that plays
basketball with the male lead the blink
and you'll miss a gay character the
Disney will Pat itself on the back about
Kid Sister Kid Sister wherever I froze
she goes and The Fifth Element
rise of icewalker
well almost only three years old and
he's already doing observational comedy
every arendellian ship has a compartment
waterproof that's very clever although
it does make me wonder why they don't
just make the whole chip waterproof
[Music]
[Music]
Fang heart spine Talon and tail long ago
the five lands live together in harmony
then everything changed when the Drew
Nation attacked only the dragons could
stop them but when the world needed the
most they vanished 500 years past and
Raya discovered the last dragon a water
dragon named sisu and although her magic
skills are great she has a lot to learn
before she's ready to save anyone but
Raya believes sisu can save the world
riotar the last Air Dragon the Avatar
the I mean Raya and The Last Dragon
journey to commandra a Melting Pot of
Southeast Asian cultures and East Asian
voice actors to meet Raya an orphan
Warrior Princess and total Dragon nerd I
might be a little bit of a dragon nerd
you're not the only dragon nerd here
which in a world created by dragons mean
she's super religious Raya will find a
savior who can walk on water when she
awakens sisu an orphaned cross between a
Thai Naga and a stretched out My Little
Pony who can disguise herself as a cross
between Aquafina and an e-girl on
laundry day together sisu will teach
Raya the importance of learning to trust
others while the movie will teach you to
never trust anyone in a different world
maybe we could have been friends you're
going to tell me where I can find those
other Dragon Gem pieces whose baby
what
you have to give a little trust first
it was foolish to trust someone from fat
don't come any closer you're saying give
people a chance but you're showing that
chaos is a letter travel across this
richly detailed land so quickly you wish
they had an avatar length TV series to
explore it further as you spend barely
enough time with the orphan Boon a
tragic victim of millennial hustle
culture I'm captain Boone the owner chef
and Chief Financial Officer of the
shrimp oil noi a tiny orphan martial
artist who feels like an exchange
student from the boss baby franchise
and Tall a likely orphan who's lost his
only child hey wait a second Raya sisu
boo noi Tong did Disney just pull off
the rare quintuple orphan gang Bravo
that has some really efficient parent
killing right there Heroes beware dark
clouds are gathering on the horizon not
metaphorically the bad guys literally
dark clouds because when you unleash the
imagination of Disney animators these
days they'll come back with what if
Cloud but bad and with a villain this
Lane you better hope the Real Enemy was
inside us all along or whatever as the
main antagonist turns out to be raya's
on-again off again maybe friendship
maybe something more with namari she may
have doomed them all when they were kids
it's fangs now
she may have doomed them all again when
they grew up
she may be dooming everyone outside of
her own tribe
we need all the jump pieces we could do
that safely but when you really think
about it aren't the heroes just as much
to blame for triggering the end of the
world you're as much to blame for sisu's
death as I am
actually no no she is not I'm sorry but
no we've been watching the movie you
shot her no so try to stomach a story
that feels like it was let's say
reincarnated from another franchise with
enough 2010s banter to repeatedly take
you out of it do you mean Captain pop
and lock over there here I was worried
you were gonna end up becoming a cat
lady something tells me you're not
besties blang is my thing but even on a
crappy laptop screen you'll be rewarded
with better visuals than the iTunes
visualizer on Edibles I mean just look
at that water since seeing how real that
looks it's like a water deep fake if I
were real water I'd be worried
story
an exclusive dating app failcore this
Alan tutic even remember how to sound
like people anymore
Zuko I know everything there is to know
about the shrimp in business let me see
that tongue avoid the noise Daniel dead
Kim and when you really want to see the
b word but you're in a Disney movie
She's the backstabbing Venturi bye-bye
Ben turies pay up in Turkey let's finish
this Venturi bye bye benturi no good
benturi's
now that's not a very nice way to
describe an old friend
The Life Aquatic with team sisu
whoa I got the glow look calling
yourself The Last Dragon if you must but
don't compare yourself to the real ass
Dragon you're not gonna win
[Music]
[Music]
from the studio they colonized your
childhood comes the latest culture to
get strip mined by Disney for anything
that can turn into movies merch or theme
parks but these days they've been doing
it respectfully with great characters
and catchy songs so truce and Kanto
return to Colombia back in the 19
something or others and stay in the
magical family's magic Casita a house
that's always listening the house isn't
going to decorate itself
sorry with a cousin who can hear a pin
drop
[Music]
a cousin who controls an army of spies
the rats told me everything and a creepy
Uncle watching through the walls how
long have you been back here truly the
worst place on Earth to be a teenage
girl and me teenage girl Mirabelle the
family's only muggle aside from the
standard Disney power that lets you
freeze time she'll battle high
expectations inadequacy and literal
burnout
as she struggles to understand why she
wasn't granted a special gift though if
you ask me her gift is living rent-free
in a house that cleans itself while her
siblings get a lifetime sentence of
community service when they turn five
when you serve this community
Mira you have it so easy Let It Go
that's why I'm what we're saying bro
smuggle a pen and Pad into the theater
because there's so many characters in
this one even the characters can't keep
track of the characters wait who's
assistant who's the cause there's so
many people how do you give them
Australia okay okay as a magic candle
gives three old Generations a superpower
until it ran out of good ideas and
started handing out curses there's
Louisa who's super strong great mom can
heal the sick with food awesome Peppa's
mood changes the weather that's more
like a punishment though right you're
lucky
Antonio can talk to animals which is
cool until you hear your friends eat
your other friends don't eat those
hat this guy can shape-shift what's that
good for Crime stop pretending your
donor so you can have seconds where's
the shot Dolores says super Hearing in a
house with two married couples definite
curse Bruno can see the future but
mostly just the bad stuff Big Time curse
and Isabella grows flowers come on
candle get your head out of your wax if
you can't think of anything useful just
magic up some birth control
gasp as their once perfect home starts
to become a crack house now it's up to
Mirabelle to discover why and defeat the
evil villain at the center of it all not
Bruno he's just lazy you know the
mountains around the Encanto are pretty
tall and uh like I said free food and
everything no the real antagonist in
this movie is getting gas lit by your
grandma the magic is strong everything
is fine there is nothing wrong with La
Casa Madrigal the magic is strong and so
are the drinks not exactly Jafar level
Evil but there's something off about
this abuela if that is your real name
oh it is your real name just Grandma in
Spanish well that must have been hard to
grow up with so enjoy a story about
complex emotions and long simmering
resentments then I'll get tied up neatly
in a few minutes tops API over to it but
if you're too stubborn to just I see you
and I hear you but who cares when the
colors are this bright the dancing is
this fluid and the music is this catchy
because lin-manuel is keeping the hot
streak alive with one hard-rending
oscar-nominated song and three other
jams that you'll be singing for months
like the magic powers that cross over
serious issue song
[Music]
no disorder she's either happy or she'll
drown you in the sea my deal Bruno
here's her deal she uses food to stuff
up how you feel
[Music]
if she's repressed imagine how I feel
mom what this family means is therapy
needs some therapy
I guess I'm lucky that all I have is
anxiety cause this family means all the
therapy oh crap the lin-manuel is trying
to tell us something song
foreign
[Music]
money's great
and the song that you'll not be named
please don't stop singing Bruno got no
no we can't stop singing Bruno
help it was my way
[Music]
again again
[Music]
[Music]
story
no Dora the Explorer Luigi's Mansion
swole Team Six
instagrammer the wrong kid doored the
changeling no fart goes unheard where
video game turkey legs come from Gail
weathers Jose exotic another easy
paycheck for Alan tudik and it took
Disney this long to realize Cappy bars
are adorable hello
Disney's Haunted by your tragic past
mansion
when does Disney have against Bruno's
Bruno